Salut, moi, c'est Guillaume Hachez. Bienvenue dans Septante Minutes Avec. Une fois n'est pas coutume, cette semaine, on laisse la Belgique de côté pour s'intéresser au Vatican.
Frédéric Martel est mon invité et il a publié ce mois-ci Sodoma, une belle brique de six cent cinquante pages qui décrit la double vie homosexuelle que connaissent de nombreux prêtres au Saint Siège et ailleurs.
Une confession avant de lancer l'interview. Pour une série de raisons, je n'ai reçu le livre que la veille de notre entrevue, ce qui rendait sa lecture juste impossible.
C'est pour ça que cet épisode est un peu plus court et ne dure que quarante minutes. On retrouve sans plus attendre Frédéric Martel.
Bonjour à tous. Aujourd'hui, mon invité est Frédéric Martel. Après avoir terminé quatre masters en sciences sociales, philosophie, sciences politiques et droit public, il est devenu chef du bureau du livre à l'ambassade de France en Roumanie.
Il a travaillé au sein du syndicat CFDT. Il a travaillé également au sein du cabinet de la ministre Martine Aubry, ainsi qu'auprès de l'ancien Premier ministre Michel Rocard en France, attaché culturel à l'ambassade de France aux États-Unis.
Aujourd'hui, un journaliste virulent de gauche, disent certains. Il est aujourd'hui chercheur, écrivain, ainsi qu'animateur pour Radio France pour l'émission Soft Power.
Frédéric Martel bonjour.
Bonjour.
Vous publiez ce mois-ci Sodoma, un livre qui explore la sociologie de l'homosexualité au sein du Vatican. D'abord, un mot sur votre parcours.
Je l'ai dit, j'ai fait un rapide tour de votre CV. C'est un parcours assez varié. Le journalisme, ça n'était pas une évidence immédiatement pour vous ?
Si, j'étais journaliste plus tôt, ça apparaît pas dans ce CV. J'ai été journaliste vers seize, dix-sept ans dans un quotidien régional, comme souvent on commence, et aussi dans une radio locale.
Donc, en réalité, j'ai un parcours journalistique constant toute ma vie, dès le début.
Ça vous a guidé et puis vous vous en êtes petit à petit détourné—
Non, non—
Pour la politique
...non, pas du tout. J'ai gardé, j'ai continué à faire du journalisme. Simplement, j'ai pas fait de la politique au sens politique du terme.
C'est-à-dire que j'ai été essentiellement la plume du ministre. Et donc quand on est une plume, on est une forme de journaliste.
C'est-à-dire qu'on écrit, on continue à exercer, entre guillemets, sa plume. Donc c'était pas contradictoire avec ce parcours initial—
Très bien
...et futur.
D'accord. Une série d'intérêts, toutefois, quand même assez variés dans votre parcours, hein, la politique, la technologie, le Vatican. Qu'est-ce que—
Alors, ça, c'est nouveau, pour le coup.
Oui
Le Vatican, c'est quelque chose... Je ne suis pas catholique ou en tout cas, j'ai été catholique jusqu'à l'âge de douze ans, donc comme tout le monde.
Oui, comme tout le monde, oui.
Donc c'est au fond, pour dire d'une expression française, j'ajoute une corne à mon arc. C'est quelque chose que je n'ai pas.
Un talent, si vous voulez, entre guillemets, de manière un peu présomptueuse, c'est un talent que je n'avais pas. J'ai travaillé sur le Vatican seulement pour ce livre-ci—
Oui
...depuis quatre ans quoi.
Et donc, d'où est-ce que ça vous est venu cet intérêt soudain, que vous n'aviez pas précédemment pour, voilà, le Vatican ?
C'est un livre sur le Vatican, mais c'est un livre sur le Vatican gay.
Mh.
Et donc du coup, comme j'ai déjà écrit sur la question homosexuelle, c'est un lien finalement assez normal avec mes sujets précédents.
Puis c'est aussi un livre sur le pouvoir, sur l'hypocrisie, sur la double vie. Et ça, c'est des questions que j'ai traitées par le passé.
Ce qui vous amène au Vatican, c'est l'angle homosexuel, l'angle du pouvoir.
Oui, au fond, la formule célèbre d'Oscar Wilde, reprise par House of Cards : « Everything is about sex, except sex, which is about power. »
C'est une formule intéressante. Vous avez interrogé pour ce livre des cardinaux, des prêtres, des gardes suisses. Vous avez logé au Vatican pendant un certain temps. Vous avez même
logé dans une série d'appartements, je crois, au sein du Vatican.
Vous dites que l'importance de l'homosexualité au sein du Vatican est une clé pour comprendre une réponse tranchée de l'Église catholique face aux questions de la libération des mœurs sexuelles.
Est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer cette votre théorie, votre approche ?
En fait, la question homosexuelle est une question dont on a beaucoup parlé dans l'Église depuis longtemps. On en a parlé à travers de multitudes affaires.
On en a parlé à travers la question d'un lobby gay qui aurait peut-être
éventuellement fait démissionner Benoît XVI.
On en a parlé à travers des affaires de prostitution, des chem sex party, c'est-à-dire des soirées avec drogue et sexe qui ont eu lieu à l'intérieur même du Vatican, dans la Congrégation pour la doctrine de la foi.
Bref, c'est un sujet qui était assez récurrent, mais paradoxalement, il n'a jamais été traité en lui-même. On l'a toujours vu sous les scandales, on l'a toujours vu sous ses débordements.
Et ça permettait au fond de dire : « Oui, d'accord, il y a toujours, là comme ailleurs, des brebis égarées, des petits scandales et que tout ça n'affecte pas le système lui-même qui est pur.
» Ce que je montre dans ce livre, c'est l'inverse. C'est que le problème et la question, c'est pas celle de ces petits scandales, mais c'est la banalité quotidienne,
la vie homosexuelle très majoritaire, d'une majorité silencieuse à l'intérieur même du Vatican.
Donc, une homosexualité qui est vécue au quotidien au sein du Vatican, mais qui n'est pas assumée, qui n'est pas publique, qui est secrète.
Oui, en fait, il y a
fifty shades of gay. Il y a beaucoup de sortes de gays. Vous avez d'abord des homophiles, c'est-à-dire des gens qui sont homosexuels par leur sensibilité, par leur
psychologie, leur culture, mais qui ne vont pas agir et ne vont pas avoir d'actes homosexuels.
Ils vont rester chastes. Ça, c'est une composante assez essentielle ou en tout cas importante au niveau des cardinaux qui, vous savez, ont quatre-vingt, quatre-vingt-dix ans.
Donc, on peut penser que l'homophilie et la chasteté sont possibles.
Ensuite, vous avez des cardinaux homosexuels, mais qui le vivent très très mal et qui vont se flageller ou être dans la haine de soi, se culpabiliser.
Ensuite, vous allez avoir des cardinaux qui ont un amant, mais qui le gardent très secret, parfois un assistant, un secrétaire, un garde du corps.
Et puis, il y a des cardinaux qui vont avoir de multiples partenaires, ou bien à l'intérieur ou bien à l'extérieur. Si c'est à l'intérieur, c'est avec des séminaristes, c'est avec les prêtres, etc.
Ou alors à l'extérieur. Et là, ça va être très souvent de la prostitution, parfois au cours des voyages à l'international, lors du tourisme,
tourisme sexuel par exemple, et parfois dans d'autres situations compliquées.
Mh.
Et puis bien sûr, il y a, mais c'est un très petit nombre de cas, des prêtres qui vont être dans l'abus sexuel et la violence et le viol.
Mh. Voire la pédophilie.
Oui, la violence et le viol sur majeur ou la pédophilie si c'est des moins de quinze ans.
Yes. Un large dossier, un dossier lourd que vous dévoilez ce mois-ci dans ce livre. Comment est-ce que vous expliquez que ça ne soit jamais sorti auparavant ?
Voilà, vous parlez de réseaux de prostitution, vous parlez de drague au sein du Vatican, vous parlez de relations sexuelles récurrentes, tout ce qu'on imagine absolument interdit au Vatican.
On imaginerait a priori qu'il n'y a absolument aucune activité sexuelle au sein du Vatican. Vous dites aujourd'hui que c'est absolument faux, que c'est même le contraire.
Comment est-ce que vous expliquez que ça ne soit jamais sorti, que vous soyez le premier aujourd'hui en 2019 ?
Non, tout est un peu sorti. Il y a eu beaucoup, encore une fois, d'articles—
Oui
...parfois de livres à scandale qui ont évoqué des bouts de cette histoire. Mais au fond, d'abord, ceux qui le faisaient étaient sans doute un peu homophobes et donc ils étaient contents de
choper, si je puis dire, en français pas très argotique, très argotique, une victime et donc quelqu'un dont il dénonçait l'homosexualité.
Ça, c'était assez fréquent, ça a été beaucoup dit. Ce qui n'avait pas été fait, c'était une étude systématique sur plusieurs pontificats au Vatican et dans trente pays du monde sur la question homosexuelle dans tous ses aspects, y compris
la vie banale, secrète d'un grand nombre de prélats qui vivent tout ça très mal.
Il faut bien voir que c'est une homosexualité qui est vécue dans la souffrance, la douleur—
La torture
...le mensonge, la torture et parfois même le mensonge à soi-même. C'est-à-dire qu'un certain nombre d'homophiles ne savent sans doute même pas qu'ils sont homophiles eux-mêmes.
Et comment est-ce que vous expliquez alors que cette vaste enquête à l'échelle de trente pays sur cette homophilie, cette homosexualité
sublimée, ignorée, cachée, comment est-ce que vous expliquez qu'elle n'arrive qu'aujourd'hui, alors que c'est une institution de deux mille ans ?
Bien d'abord, il faut voir qui pouvait faire ce livre. Si vous êtes vaticaniste, c'est-à-dire un journaliste spécialisé sur le Vatican, et vous faites ce livre, vous n'avez plus de job. C'est fini.
Si vous êtes italien, vous avez un peu de difficulté, vous avez peur finalement de faire ça. Et vous êtes
un peu éloigné, au fond, de ce type de sujet parce que si vous les traitez trop frontalement dans la presse, dans l'édition, ça reste difficile, même encore aujourd'hui en Italie.
D'ailleurs, mon livre sort en français, d'abord en anglais. Il sort aussi en italien le même jour, mais parce qu'il sort en traduction d'un livre français.
Et donc il y a au fond une protection un peu qui est faite par le fait qu'il sorte dans plusieurs langues. Ensuite, il y a la difficulté pour un hétérosexuel, et je regrette un peu de dire ça, mais pour un journaliste hétérosexuel,
il ne va pas avoir les codes, il ne va pas connaître le système, il ne va pas avoir les réseaux d'accès à l'intérieur du Vatican.
Et puis enfin, quant aux homosexuels, aux journalistes gays, très souvent parce qu'ils sont gays assumés, ils vont être un peu militants et du coup, ils vont être assez hostiles au Vatican et ne pas le connaître très très bien.
Et donc voilà pourquoi il fallait que ce soit un Français. Il fallait que ce soit pas un vaticaniste. Il fallait que ce soit quelqu'un qui avait les codes pour faire ce livre.
Dans tous les aspects que vous avez cités, la partie qui m'est forcément la plus mystérieuse, puisque je ne suis moi-même pas un homosexuel, vous parlez de codes à déchiffrer, vous parlez
des vêtements, vous parlez de la cérémonie, des messes, des façons de se mouvoir.
Quelque chose qui, moi, ne m'apparaît pas du tout. Vous expliquez que l'homosexualité transparaît dans ces choses-là.
Est-ce que vous pouvez nous en parler un petit peu ?
Alors d'abord, c'est même quelque chose qu'on m'a reproché. On dit : vous—
vous dépeignez, vous faites une description très caricaturale, vous avez des stéréotypes, vous êtes un peu, comment dire, critique sur des choses finalement très banales.
D'abord, vous savez, le chercheur, le sociologue, il s'intéresse aux détails et c'est ces détails qui lui parlent. Et d'autre part, ces stéréotypes, ces caricatures, c'est pas moi qui les invente, ce sont eux qui les ont.
Quand vous voyez les robes du cardinal Burke, quand vous voyez la manière très féminisée qu'il a de se comporter, quand vous voyez chez d'autres cardinaux leur proximité avec un nombre insensé d'éphèbes, etc.
Vous êtes vraiment avec des gens qui sont des caricatures et qui, au fond, méritent d'être décrits tels que les faits sont.
Et c'est eux qui ont ces stéréotypes et qui les survalorisent. Donc la description caricaturale, elle est de leur fait.
Donc c'est la féminité de—
Pas forcément la féminité, mais tout un tas de facteurs qui peuvent jouer et être de manière compliquée.
D'accord. Je vous avoue que ce n'est pas forcément beaucoup plus clair à mes yeux, mais...
Non, mais c'est très simple. C'est une... les codes homosexuels sont assez précis, surtout qu'on n'est pas en face de cardinaux.
Les cardinaux que j'ai rencontrés, ils ont soixante-dix, soixante-quinze, quatre-vingt, quatre-vingt-cinq, parfois quatre-vingt-dix ans.
On n'est pas avec des gens de 2019. Leur rapport à la sexualité et éventuellement à l'homosexualité, elle date des années quarante, des années cinquante.
Ces gens qui ont eu vingt ans à ce moment-là. Pour
les comprendre, il faut se reporter à l'homosexualité de cette époque-là, c'est-à-dire à la double vie, c'est-à-dire au mariage de complaisance, à la chasteté vécue comme une sublimation de l'homosexualité,
aux médisances de ce monde gay, à un rapport, parler beaucoup au féminin avec les gens, etc., etc.
Donc, pour comprendre ces codes d'aujourd'hui, il faut connaître ceux des années cinquante.
Ça a beaucoup de sens quand vous parlez donc des cardinaux de quatre-vingt, quatre-vingt-cinq, voire plus. Ça a beaucoup de sens.
Les prêtres plus jeunes, ceux qui ont vingt, trente ans, ceux qui ont mon âge, est-ce que vous observez aussi ces codes-là ?
Est-ce que ces codes sont inscrits dans le marbre ? Est-ce que ça concerne aussi les plus jeunes ou bien est-ce que c'est strictement un truc de vieux ?
Non, mais d'abord, je me concentre quand même sur le Vatican et donc sur le Collège Cardinalis. Donc c'est quand même des gens qui ont forcément—
Forcément, inévitablement, un certain âge, oui
D'autre part, sur les générations les plus jeunes, disons sur les séminaristes qui ont en général vingt-cinq, vingt-huit ans, on est essentiellement avec des gens qui vont être, comment dire, dans différentes identités.
Vous avez des gens qui sont très identitaires, de droite assez dure et ceux-là refusent très fortement leur
homosexualité lorsque c'est le cas, mais ils vont être dans des schémas, je dirais, d'une homosexualité des années 30, mais revisités au goût du jour.
Donc les choses ont changé, mais elles n'ont pas tellement changé, c'est ça que vous dites.
Voilà. Après, il y a d'autres cas de figure. Vous avez aussi toujours une attraction pour des homosexuels qui aiment bien
l'homoérotisme assez généralisé du Vatican, par les habits, la musique, la culture, les figures, et ça, c'est quelque chose qui continue à attirer les homosexuels.
Les homosexuels sont attirés à l'idée de rentrer dans les ordres et de devenir—
Bien sûr, oui.
Oui, ça, c'est intéressant. J'aimerais parler un instant de la réaction du monde catholique à votre ouvrage. Évidemment, il vient de sortir.
On sait que le pape François en a reçu, d'après ce que j'ai compris, une copie en main propre. On sait que les journaux catholiques ont reçu des copies et ont eu l'occasion de le lire, enfin d'en faire la critique.
Ce que j'ai pu en lire, c'est généralement qu'on ne reniait pas les faits, mais qu'on critiquait finalement
la forme, que la forme était, je crois dans le journal catholique La Croix : « Les faits sont graves, mais ne sont pas niés par le journal.
Mais en revanche, la forme est toute rancière », disait-il, si j'ai bonne mémoire.
Oui, mais le travail du journaliste, c'est d'inventer des formes et c'est d'assumer une forme subversive quand le sujet le nécessite, ce qui est le cas.
Et donc ce livre n'était pas possible, en tout cas à mes yeux, avec une autre forme. Et donc la forme est inextricablement liée au contenu très spécifique de ce livre.
Mh. Mh. Les réactions que j'ai pu voir, il y avait aussi ce qu'on appelle en anglais du whataboutism, c'est-à-dire que plutôt que de se plonger au cœur de la problématique que vous soulevez, hein, l'hypocrisie, le culte du secret,
on va plutôt dire : « Oui, mais pourquoi est-ce qu'il ne parle pas de la sexualité dans le monde juif ou dans le monde musulman ?
» Enfin, une façon finalement de contourner, une défense qui est plutôt une esquive en réalité.
D'abord, premièrement, mon sujet est l'Église catholique. Et deuxièmement, c'est aussi un sujet qui a une spécificité, à savoir le célibat et la chasteté des prêtres, qui n'existent ni dans le monde musulman, ni dans le monde juif.
Et donc ça a des effets particuliers sur cette question homosexuelle qui n'existe pas, me semble-t-il, en tout cas pas à cette dose-là dans d'autres mondes.
Il va sans dire que, et c'est toujours compliqué quand on essaye de faire le lien entre homosexualité, homophobie et crime de nature pédophile.
Il faut évidemment prendre de grandes pincettes, expliquer que ça n'est pas du tout la même chose. Mais vous expliquez que c'est le culte du secret,
le fait de sublimer son homosexualité, de la renier, qui permet indirectement cette omerta, le fait,
le fait de vouloir protéger les prêtres pédophiles.
C'est ça que vous dites dans votre livre ?
Oui, enfin, c'est beaucoup plus complexe que ça. D'abord, comme vous le rappelez, il n'y a aucun lien entre homosexualité et abus sexuels.
Les abus sexuels sont essentiellement hétérosexuels, selon toutes les études dont on dispose. Ils sont dans les familles hétérosexuelles d'abord, dans les écoles, dans la structure scolaire.
Et les victimes en sont essentiellement des femmes ou des filles. Donc, c'est un système extrêmement hétérosexuel et les abus sexuels sont d'abord et avant tout hétérosexuels.
Après, il y a dans l'Église une spécificité qui est que d'abord, on est dans un monde très masculin. On est aussi dans un monde où le catéchisme, les aumôneries sont très masculines, les scouts, etc.
Et donc, il y a par sa nature même une proportion plus forte d'abus qui sont de nature homosexuelle, 80 %, 85 % environ.
Donc ça veut dire que dans l'Église, les abus sexuels sont essentiellement des abus homosexuels. Pourquoi ça ? Il y a beaucoup de raisons, c'est très complexe.
Ce ne sont pas des situations individuelles simples à expliquer. C'est pas forcément des questions systématiquement... D'abord, vous avez,
pour essayer de trouver des explications, une homophobie qui vient d'une homosexualité non assumée, refoulée, sublimée, la haine de soi, qui peut, dans certains cas, heureusement fort peu nombreux, mener à des abus sexuels.
On pense que c'est 2, 3 % des prêtres qui sont concernés, ce qui fait à la fois beaucoup au niveau mondial, mais très peu finalement par rapport à l'ensemble des prêtres. Deuxièmement,
il y a une culture du secret très forte dans l'Église qui a contribué à protéger des prêtres philo-pédophiles par ce secret, alors même que cette culture du secret était d'abord faite pour protéger l'homosexualité des cardinaux.
Et donc, il y a eu une espèce de double abus des abuseurs, puisqu'ils ont abusé du système de l'Église pour être protégés alors même que ce n'était pas l'objectif de l'Église.
Il y a une culture du cléricalisme très très forte dans l'Église qui vise à toujours protéger l'Église, l'institution plutôt que les individus.
Et puis enfin, il y a des formes de chantage qui font qu'un évêque, très souvent, qui va protéger un prêtre abuseur, va avoir tendance à avoir peur de ce qui se passe.
Et comme beaucoup d'entre eux, de ces évêques-là, sont homosexuels, ils vont avoir tendance à protéger
le prêtre, non pas simplement pour le protéger, mais pour se protéger eux-mêmes, notamment parce qu'ils ont peur de la médiatisation, ils ont peur d'un procès, ils ont peur du scandale qui pourrait rejaillir sur eux.
Et c'est ça qui les terrorise.
Mh. Mh. Mh. La réponse à ce constat que je répète, j'ai l'impression que l'Église catholique ne renie pas.
Bon, évidemment, très peu de jours se sont passés depuis la publication de votre livre. La réponse que j'ai pu observer jusqu'à présent, ça n'est pas une réponse du déni.
Personne ne vous donne tort réellement, mais c'est intéressant de voir que les approches sont très différentes en réponse au constat que vous, vous faites.
On a par exemple pu voir une personnalité bien connue en Belgique qui est Monseigneur Léonard expliquer que la réelle solution pour empêcher les actes d'abus pédophiles au sein de l'Église catholique,
c'était en réalité de mieux filtrer à la porte d'entrée et d'être sûr que l'homosexualité, les prêtres homosexuels n'étaient pas les bienvenus au sein de l'Église. Ce qui—
Oui, mais ça, c'est une parole homophobe—
Exactement.
Une parole illégale, parce qu'aujourd'hui, on ne peut pas interdire l'accès au séminaire, en réalité, aux homosexuels. Il a tort.
Et c'est aussi une parole très problématique parce qu'elle dénote une obsession, une homophobie caricaturale qui parfois, je ne connais rien à la vie privée de Monsieur Léonard, mais peut être le fait, on l'a
vu sur de nombreux cas, de prêtres qui assument mal leur propre identité,
parfois, quelquefois homosexuelle. Et—
Et qui met en lien surtout dans ce cas-ci, pédophilie et homosexualité. Ce qu'on—
Oui, mais vous savez, si on supprime les homosexuels des séminaires et de l'Église, il n'y a plus de séminaire et il n'y a plus d'Église.
Aujourd'hui, ils forment la très grande majorité de l'Église. Donc voilà la réalité. Après, chacun peut penser ce qu'il veut de ce phénomène.
Vous expliquez aussi que l'importance de l'homosexualité au sein du Vatican est aussi, et au sein de l'Église catholique en général, est aussi ce qui explique ce que vous appelez une hyper misogynie.
Ben on est face très clairement à un monde sans femmes. Lorsque vous êtes au Vatican, il n'y a pas de femmes. Lorsque vous êtes dans l'Église, c'est un monde
où les femmes sont souvent rejetées, et mises dans les situations les plus, les moins socialement valorisantes.
Je parle même pas des femmes qui sont violées, notamment des bonnes sœurs, puisque désormais, même le pape François a reconnu tous les problèmes d'abus sexuels sur des femmes.
La réalité, c'est que vous avez énormément de scandales qui démontrent qu'il y a un vrai problème dans cette Église.
Et je parle pas simplement des abus sexuels. Vous avez eu énormément de prêtres qui ont été outés, c'est-à-dire dont on a révélé l'homosexualité.
Il y a eu beaucoup de cas de pornographie, il y a beaucoup de cas de chemsex party, c'est-à-dire de soirées avec de la drogue et du sexe homosexuel.
Il y a eu beaucoup aussi de prostitution. Donc tout ça montre qu'il y a un problème général dans l'Église. Et ce problème, ben aujourd'hui, ne peut pas avoir la solution unique qui serait d'en supprimer les homosexuels.
La seule solution, me semble-t-il, mais ce n'est pas à moi d'en juger, c'est de sortir de la culture du mensonge et de défendre la vérité.
Défendre la vérité, sortir de la culture du mensonge. Est-ce que vous avez un quelconque espoir, un réel espoir que c'est ce que l'Église va faire ?
Qu'est-ce que vous pressentez à l'avenir, quand vous observez, voilà, la réponse de l'Église ?
Honnêtement, je ne suis pas prescripteur en la matière. C'est-à-dire que mon objectif n'est pas d'essayer de...
Si vous voulez, la question de changer l'Église n'est pas mon sujet. Je ne dis pas que je ne veux pas le faire. J'espère que mon livre va contribuer à changer l'Église.
Mais changer l'Église, c'est pas le travail du chercheur
ou du journaliste. C'est le travail de ceux qui sont catholiques et de ceux aussi qui font partie de ce système, et notamment des prêtres et des évêques,
qui, eux seuls, peuvent éventuellement faire évoluer cette maison.
Mh. Oui, donc là, vous donnez finalement les clés, vous donnez l'information qui doit in fine permettre d'approcher les réformes.
C'est ça que vous dites ?
Absolument.
Oui. Mais vous n'avez pas idée de quelle réforme ça pourrait être ?
Non, c'est pas que j'ai pas idée, mais je dirais que c'est— moi, je fais mon travail, c'est-à-dire que je suis dans une analyse d'un système, je le décris, je ne suis pas là pour le, comment dire, pour le...
Enfin, la réforme de l'Église n'est pas ma mission.
Ce n'est pas votre mission, d'accord.
Parce que je ne suis pas catholique et parce que ce n'est pas mon travail. C'est quelque chose dont... Enfin, au fond, les gens doivent s'approprier mon livre, le critiquer, le défendre.
Ils en font ce qu'ils veulent, mais ce livre, d'une certaine manière, ne m'appartient plus.
Mh.
Il dépasse son auteur et il est d'intérêt général. Et à chacun de savoir l'utiliser à bon escient.
Ce n'est pas votre mission et ce n'est pas votre objectif avec ce livre, mais accessoirement, à côté de ça, si je vous pose la question de ce que vous espéreriez voir comme changement, vous ne répondez pas ?
Non, parce que je ne peux pas prescrire des choses qui sont en plus de l'ordre de la doctrine. Et vous savez, il y a une règle absolue en France, la distinction entre la religion et le laïc.
On appelle ça la laïcité. Et donc moi, j'appartiens à cette catégorie des chercheurs qui sont des chercheurs laïcs et c'est pas à moi à faire changer l'Église.
Mh, mh, mh. Revenons un instant sur vos— j'allais dire vos confrères, mais qui ne sont pas vos confrères, donc les vaticanistes, donc cette classe de journalistes spécialisés sur le sujet du Vatican.
C'était au fond, d'après ce que vous dites, quelque part un secret de polichinelle, quelque chose qui se savait, mais qui ne se disait pas parce que vous disiez : on est italien, on a peur, on est vaticaniste, on a encore plus peur.
Est-ce que les vaticanistes, in fine, implicitement, d'après ce que vous dites, ne sont pas complices de ce culte du secret et de ce qui a permis de camoufler, voilà, tous les actes qu'on a connus ?
Non, mais je ne crois pas. Enfin, si un vaticaniste a eu connaissance d'abus sexuels et qu'il ne l'a pas dénoncé, c'est grave.
Mais il ne s'agit pas de ça.
Il s'agit de l'importance de l'homosexualité aussi du Vatican.
Oui, ça après, ils ont le droit de pas évoquer l'homosexualité de leurs collègues. Donc, je ne pense pas que cela doive leur être reproché.
Chacun traite cette question comme il veut. Mais surtout, c'est vrai que c'est un peu un secret de polichinelle et que d'une certaine manière, chacun connaissait au moins une partie de cette histoire.
Vous savez, ce livre, c'est un peu un puzzle. Chaque pièce du puzzle, chacun en a un petit bout. Et moi, au fond, j'ai rassemblé les pièces du puzzle pour en faire un livre.
Mh. Donc, ce que vous dénoncez à travers ce livre, c'est une hypocrisie. Et vous montrez également les conséquences sociétales, culturelles, de cette hypocrisie donc.
Absolument. C'est ça le livre.
Celle qui revient le plus souvent, évidemment, c'est la façon dont l'Église a géré les actes pédophiles.
Est-ce que vous en voyez d'autres ? Donc on a évoqué une certaine misogynie. Est-ce que vous en voyez d'autres, des conséquences de cette culture du secret ?
Bah de toute façon, toutes les institutions ont une forme de culture du secret. C'est d'ailleurs ce qu'on appelle dans d'autres mondes, on appelle ça la raison d'État dans le monde politique.
C'est-à-dire, au fond, la raison d'État, c'est quoi ? Depuis Mazarin ou Richelieu, c'est que vous mentez si c'est nécessaire pour le bien de l'institution.
De ce point de vue, l'Église catholique n'est pas différente de la politique, de l'Armée rouge,
de, je ne sais pas, la campagne électorale de monsieur X ou le fonctionnement de telle grande entreprise, telle multinationale qui fonctionne exactement de la même manière.
Le problème, c'est que si elle ment sur l'essentiel de sa doctrine, elle n'est plus crédible, elle perd sa crédibilité. De ce point de vue, l'Église, dès lors qu'elle va protéger des abuseurs d'enfants, perd sa légitimité.
Vous dites que vous avez collecté des témoignages concernant
des gay sex party. Vous dites que vous avez collecté des témoignages qui expliquaient que, je crois, septante pour cent des dignitaires du Vatican étaient homosexuels.
C'est bien juste ? J'ai bien lu ça ?
Moi, je n'avance pas de chiffres moi-même parce que je considère qu'il n'est pas possible de les prouver.
Il n'est pas possible de les connaître.
Mh.
Donc, je ne dévoile pas ces éléments-là parce que je ne les connais pas. En revanche, ce que je fais, c'est, je dirais, de citer un certain nombre de gens qui font leur propre évaluation.
Quand vous êtes dans un séminaire, par exemple, jésuite ou je ne sais pas, dominicain, et que vous venez, vous constatez qu'il y a,
vous connaissez les vingt-trois ou je sais pas, les vingt-quatre personnes qui font partie, vous pouvez être certain que dix pour cent, vingt pour cent, trente pour cent.
Dans ce cas-là, vous pouvez donner un chiffre et moi, je le cite le cas échéant.
Parlons l'instant du pape François, qui incarne un certain changement dans la ligne, j'ai envie de dire, la ligne éditoriale du Vatican,
puisque voilà, c'est le pape qui avait dit dans sa sortie de l'avion il y a quelques années : Qui suis-je pour juger ?
Est-ce qu'on a avec le pape François une approche différente de la question de l'homophobie, de l'homosexualité ?
Disons qu'on avait sous Jean-Paul II un pape sans doute très homophobe et qui n'était pas très au courant, me semble-t-il, de ce qui se passait réellement en termes
d'abus sexuels et même d'homosexualité dans son équipe et dans les cardinaux qu'il défendait.
D'où un certain nombre de scandales que sans doute, Jean-Paul II ne maîtrisait pas, ne savait pas, ne connaissait pas.
Je pense évidemment à toute l'affaire Marcial Maciel des Légionnaires du Christ. Ensuite,
vous avez la question de Benoît XVI, qui reste un pape complexe, qui sans doute était très naïf par rapport à son entourage et dont on ne maîtrise pas non plus, qu'il ne maîtrisait pas non plus ce qui se passait vraiment dans la curie romaine.
Puis enfin, il y a François. Et François, sans doute des trois, c'est celui qui connaît le mieux ce qui se passe, qui a très bien identifié la question et le problème homosexuel et qui tente de trouver des solutions parce qu'au fond,
c'est un pape, je dirais, gorbatchévien.
Et là, je pense qu'il est important que ce pape soit aidé parce qu'il est en lutte contre une opposition très radicale, très homophobe et dont il dit lui-même que ce sont des rigides qui mènent une double vie.
Oui. Vous dites également que
l'importance de la sociologie et de la culture homosexuelle au sein du Vatican et l'homophobie donc qui en résulte, pour les raisons qu'on a évoquées, est également ce qui explique,
ben, la fameuse sortie du Vatican concernant le préservatif il y a quelques années.
C'est difficile pour moi d'affirmer ça. Ce que je constate, et ça, c'est un fait, c'est que
ceux qui prennent la décision autour du pape, et ils sont une douzaine à être très actifs dans la question du préservatif et du sida, parmi eux, beaucoup sont homosexuels.
Et donc là, il y a un paradoxe. Est-ce que c'est une décision qui est prise parce qu'ils sont homosexuels ? C'est évidemment une réponse un peu rapide.
Il y a d'autres raisons qui expliquent que le préservatif va être interdit.
En revanche, il est clair que c'est une erreur historique et même une tragédie puisqu'on va quand même avoir trente-cinq millions de morts dans ces années du sida
et que le préservatif, même si ce n'est pas l'Église, hein, qui est seule responsable, bien sûr, de ces trente-cinq millions de morts, sa position sur le préservatif n'a vraiment pas aidé à lutter contre l'épidémie.
Et là, on voit bien que c'est des positions qui sont absurdes, qui n'ont d'ailleurs aucune justification parce que rien ne justifie de choisir, au fond, entre protéger la vie et donner la mort.
Le choix était vite fait et il valait mieux encourager l'utilisation du préservatif, même si c'était contraire à la doctrine, plutôt que d'avoir des personnes qui allaient en mourir.
Le pape François, davantage conscient du problème, peut-être également aussi un peu plus ouvert d'esprit.
C'est en tout cas ce qui apparaît et c'est comme ça qu'on le présente.
Oui, c'est plus compliqué. Le pape François, c'est un mélange d'Argentin, péroniste, jésuite, qui est un jour gay friendly, l'autre jour anti-gay.
Et donc, il reste très compliqué par rapport à cette question. Donc, voilà, je pense que nous sommes face à un pape qui cherche sa voie.
C'est aussi un pape de quatre-vingt-deux ans, donc c'est pas un pape très jeune. C'est un pape qui appartient— vous voyez, il a eu vingt ans au moment de la Révolution cubaine, hein, donc c'est pas tout récent.
Et d'ailleurs, il était très marqué par Che Guevara à cette époque, ce qui est normal puisqu'il était jeune Argentin au même moment où le Che était aussi lui-même Argentin et partait à Cuba.
Donc, je dirais qu'il faut replacer tout ça dans son contexte. C'est un pape plutôt
progressiste sur les questions sociales, l'immigration, la peine de mort, la question, disons, globalement de la pauvreté, plutôt conservateur sur les questions de morale sexuelle.
Et donc, mais c'est ça qui est intéressant et le décalage qu'on observe entre
ce que vous dites à l'instant, plutôt conservateur, plutôt intolérant et cette sortie qu'il a eue il y a quelques années : qui suis-je pour juger ?
Où quand on la sort comme ça hors contexte, évidemment, je ne suis pas un vaticaniste moi-même, on a l'impression que ça veut dire : « Bah, je n'ai aucune opinion sur l'homosexualité ».
Mais vous me dites que c'est tout le contraire.
Non, je dis pas que c'est le contraire. Je dis justement que cette formule, qui, je le rappelle, est une question, c'est une réponse à une question par une question.
Donc d'une certaine manière, elle entretient un certain flou. C'est une réponse—
Une esquive ?
...jésuite extrêmement habile—
Ouais.
...et d'un grand génie jésuitique, une grande casuistique, on pourrait même dire. Voilà, je pense que c'est intéressant de l'analyser comme une étape
dans son propre cheminement sur ce sujet qui est au fond assez tolérant à l'égard des individus.
Qui suis-je pour juger l'individu en question dont on lui parlait, qui se trouve être Monseigneur Ricca, et quelle est
sa position sur des questions politiques comme le mariage gay ou comme la question de la théorie du genre, où là, pour le coup, il se montre très très réservé et très hostile.
Donc on a un pape assez compassionnel avec les individus et assez hostile à la politisation de la question gay.
Mh. J'aimerais qu'on vienne un instant sur ce qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure, des réseaux de prostitution au sein ou autour du Vatican.
Vous expliquez que les cardinaux consomment des services de prostitution majoritairement de la part d'hommes musulmans, migrants. C'est juste ?
Je parle pas de cardinaux du tout dans—
Je mélange tout, excusez-moi.
...dans ce livre. Non, non, non. Je parle essentiellement de prêtres, qui sont d'ailleurs probablement pas des prêtres du Vatican.
Beaucoup sont des prêtres romains ou italiens et d'ailleurs un Napolitain aussi, puisqu'un des prostitués que j'interviewe est Napolitain.
Et donc ce qui est intéressant, oui, c'est que vous avez— bah, d'abord, les migrants sont beaucoup des musulmans.
Ensuite, la prostitution, du coup, est une façon de gagner sa vie assez rapidement quand on n'a pas d'argent et rien à faire de sa vie, c'est évidemment de devenir prostitué.
Qu'il y ait des prêtres dans ce circuit-là me paraît pas anormal compte tenu du fait qu'il y a une homosexualité très forte chez les prêtres, qu'ils ont pas de possibilité d'avoir ces relations à domicile,
ou même de l'assumer, dans leur, au Vatican ou dans leur église et du coup, vont avoir
affaire à des prostitués de ce type.
Pourquoi aussi on fait appel à des prostitués migrants ? C'est parce qu'évidemment, c'est des gens qui parlent pas. Et vous n'avez jamais vu un migrant aller porter plainte ou aller dénoncer un cardinal ou un prêtre—
Mais vous dites qu'ils—
...au commissariat de police.
Vous dites qu'ils vous en parlaient à vous.
Oui, mais ça, c'est différent. Ils me parlent parce que d'abord, c'est généralement pas nominatif, hein, même si ça peut l'être.
C'est toujours l'anonymat, oui.
Et puis ensuite parce qu'ils ont pas forcément les noms, ils ont que des portables généralement, et puis d'autre part, c'est aussi un travail de longue haleine, hein.
Il a, m'a fallu les voir pendant longtemps, etc.
Mh, mh, mh. Et qu'est-ce qui amène finalement ces jeunes hommes prostitués musulmans à vous parler ? Quel intérêt pour eux ?
Ah ben, pas vraiment. C'est-à-dire que c'est tout un travail, c'est le travail du journaliste que d'arriver à être familier avec, de les inviter à déjeuner, de les inviter à boire un café.
Y a pas mal d'ennuis parce qu'il y a pas forcément toujours beaucoup de clients. Donc voilà. Et puis surtout d'arriver à les revoir, etc.
Je l'ai fait avec des associations de travailleurs sociaux. J'ai été aussi avec la police, j'ai été beaucoup avec des prostitués plus politiques qui avaient des raisons de parler pour décrire ce qui se passait.
Voilà un peu les différents éléments.
J'ai envie de parler un instant de l'Église catholique au sens large, en France, en Belgique, en Europe, en Occident, et ailleurs.
Comment est-ce que cette dualité, cette double vie homosexuelle qui se renie, comment est-ce que ça se concrétise pour les prêtres normaux, j'ai envie de dire ?
Oui, là, on a parlé d'un placard, c'est-à-dire d'un closet, mais qui est un placard doré finalement, puisqu'il y a de l'argent, c'est à Rome, c'est au Vatican, etc.
La vie de beaucoup de prêtres qui sont dans un placard beaucoup plus pauvre,
basique, la vie de tous les jours. Au fond, les paroisses, les églises un peu traditionnelles de Belgique, par exemple, où être homosexuel, c'est un problème,
où vous êtes souvent seul face à vos paroissiens, un peu comme dans le fameux Journal d'un curé de campagne de Bernanos, magnifiquement interprété dans le film de Robert Bresson, du même titre.
Donc, je dirais que là, on a une homosexualité qui est évidemment refoulée, qui est encore plus secrète et qui se traduit par,
par beaucoup de misère affective, sexuelle, lorsqu'elle est sublimée et refoulée.
Et donc je suis extrêmement attentif à penser à ces prêtres-là, à parler à eux d'une certaine manière aussi, parce qu'ils sont les victimes d'un système qu'ils n'ont pas contribué à créer, contrairement aux cardinaux-
Mh, ils ne contrôlent pas ce système
...qui malgré tout sont un peu responsables de cette doctrine, même si elle est ancienne, multiséculaire et que le pape décide.
Donc j'ai beaucoup d'affection et d'empathie au fond. Et dans mon livre, je parle notamment d'un prêtre à la fin que j'ai connu et qui était homosexuel et qui est mort du sida.
Et je trouve qu'on a une vraie tristesse par rapport à cette misère quotidienne-
Une tristesse chez vous en tant que témoin ou bien chez eux eux-mêmes, une souffrance ?
Non mais vous savez, quand vous êtes homosexuel, que vous vivez tout ça très très mal et qu'en plus vous allez mourir du sida, c'est quand même triste.
Et donc voilà, j'ai beaucoup d'empathie et c'est ça qui est important. Un écrivain, un auteur, il doit rester en empathie avec son sujet.
Mhm. Eux-mêmes sont victimes de quelque chose qu'ils ne contrôlent pas, contrairement aux cardinaux-
Les cardinaux aussi en sont victimes parce que c'est pas eux qui, au fond, pourraient-- au fond, personne n'était capable de faire changer cette doctrine depuis longtemps.
Ça viendra peut-être un jour. Peut-être qu'ils y contribueront d'ailleurs. Donc
peut-être qu'ils jouent un rôle. Encore que je me méfie, c'est souvent les hétérosexuels au Vatican qui sont les plus favorables à la question homosexuelle et non pas les gays.
Mais c'est un autre débat. En tout cas, voilà, je pense qu'il faut rester en empathie avec ces personnages et son sujet.
Oui. Quand on parle de ces sujets-là, on entend généralement dans la bouche de groupements catholiques, je dirais un petit peu intégristes, un petit peu extrêmes comme l'Alliance Vita, la Manif pour tous, etc.
On entend souvent deux mots qui reviennent : lobby homosexuel. À quoi est-ce que ça fait référence exactement ?
Ben au fond, le lobby homosexuel, c'est quelque chose qui a été inventé par l'extrême droite ou en tout cas par la droite extrêmement conservatrice, qui pense, dont l'analyse sur tout ça,
c'est qu'il y aurait au fond une cinquième colonne, une espèce de franc-maçonnerie secrète qui pervertirait le Vatican.
C'est l'idée que tous ces gens-là ont un peu inventée.
En réalité, c'est faux. Il n'y a pas de lobby gay au Vatican, parce qu'un lobby signifierait que vous avez des gens qui se reconnaissent comme étant homosexuels entre eux et qui vont agir pour permettre,
la progression de leur cause à travers une action politique.
Et c'est l'inverse qu'on a. D'abord, leur cause, c'est-- ils sont tous homophobes, donc il n'y a pas de défense des gays.
Ensuite, ils ne sont pas connus entre eux comme étant homosexuels. Au contraire, ils se cachent tout le temps vis-à-vis des autres.
Et enfin, c'est des gens qui n'ont pas pour vocation d'être pro-gay, mais effectivement, chacun est très homophobe. Donc c'est l'inverse d'un lobby.
Et c'est pour ça que l'analyse du lobby est une erreur majeure. Il s'agit d'une communauté, il s'agit surtout d'une majorité silencieuse.
Et ce qui est encore une fois intéressant pour mon sujet, c'est comment cette communauté va avoir des effets sur tout un tas d'éléments de la doctrine et le fonctionnement de l'Église.
Et ça, je dois dire que c'est quand même un problème considérable dont les effets nous atteignent tous et pas simplement ces personnes.
Très bien. On va bientôt devoir clôturer. Une question peut-être un peu plus personnelle sur l'avenir. Vous publiez donc ce mois-ci cette enquête d'investigation au cœur du Vatican concernant la sociologie homosexuelle du Saint Siège.
Est-ce que vous tournez la page aujourd'hui ou bien est-ce que, au contraire, l'Église va continuer à vous intéresser pour un prochain ouvrage ?
Je ne sais pas quoi vous répondre parce que, on verra.
On verra.
C'est un peu trop tôt. Le livre vient de paraître. J'ai du mal à...
Est-ce que vous avez d'autres choses à dire ou bien est-ce que pour vous-
Ben j'ai pas d'autres choses à dire parce que c'est pas un essai, c'est pas moi qui parle. Je fais une enquête, donc on pourrait imaginer que je continue à faire l'enquête.
Il y aura encore des choses à dire puisque ce n'est pas un livre personnel, ce n'est pas une position personnelle, même si évidemment, il y a beaucoup de choses que j'ai comprises.
Donc, voilà, je sais pas. Je vous laisse dans une réponse un peu évasive, là, pour conclure, parce que je ne suis pas certain à moi-même de savoir ce qui va se passer dans les semaines ou les mois à venir.
Très bien. Frédéric Martel, merci beaucoup.
Merci à vous.
Chers auditeurs, à dans deux semaines. Au revoir.
C'est déjà tout pour cet épisode un peu plus court que d'habitude. Je rappelle que le livre de Frédéric Martel s'appelle Sodoma, enquête au cœur du Vatican,
qu'il fait six cent cinquante pages et que vous pouvez le trouver en librairie pour environ vingt-cinq euros.
On se retrouve dans deux semaines pour une interview très spéciale puisque mon invité sera Ghislain Magherotte, un très grand spécialiste belge des troubles du spectre autistique,
qui a d'ailleurs reçu le titre de Chevalier de la Légion d'honneur pour l'influence qu'a eu son travail.
On tentera d'explorer ce que c'est, en fait, l'autisme, le syndrome d'Asperger, le fait que ça touche plus de gens que ce qu'on pense et les conséquences inattendues que ça peut avoir.
Bref, je suis impatient de vous faire écouter ça. Pour ne rien rater, surtout, n'oubliez pas de suivre Septante Minutes Avec sur les réseaux sociaux.
J'ai mis les liens dans la description de cet épisode. Et à vous abonner au podcast sur votre plateforme de podcast préférée, que ce soit iTunes, YouTube, Spotify, Google Podcasts ou quoi que ce soit, c'est gratuit et ça rend plus beau.
Allez, on se retrouve dans deux semaines. Ciao